في هذا الموسم ، حيث يتم تسليم حزم هدايا العطلات
إلى المنازل في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، يحذر الخبراء من أن قراصنة الشرفات
مشغولون هذا الوقت من العام ، حيث يقوم الناس فقط
بالاستيلاء على أي شيء ، لذا في بعض الأحيان قد
يكون لديك جوارب قادمة وتفكر في
سبب سرقة شخص ما أنه لا
يسرق  إنهم يسرقون
كل ما هو موجود في تلك العبوة ، وجد استطلاع أجراه
الاتحاد الوطني للبيع بالتجزئة أن
المستهلكين لديهم تفضيل قوي
للتسوق عبر الإنترنت ، حيث صرح 57 منهم
بأنهم يخططون لشراء الهدايا عبر الإنترنت هذا
الموسم وجميع عمليات التسليم هذه تشكل
هدفًا مغريًا لصوص
خبير الأمن  يقول دوغلاس باريسي إن هذه الخطوات الخمس
يمكن أن تساعد في ضمان عدم سرقة الطرود الموجودة على
عتبة داركم ، وهناك الكثير
من الأشياء التي يمكننا القيام بها لتكون
استباقيًا لا تكلف الكثير من المال.
رقم اثنين ، قم بتحديث
تعليمات التسليم واختيار
موقع الإنزال غير
الشرفة الأمامية مثل الفناء الخلفي أو الباب الجانبي في
بعض الأحيان فقط  لديك سلة مهملات على
جانب منزل أو شيء من هذا
القبيل وتشير إلى وجود سلة مهملات حمراء أو
هناك سلة مهملات حمراء هناك رقم
ثلاثة ، قم بتسليمها إلى منزل الجيران
إذا كانوا في المنزل
ووصلت الطرود أو حصلت عليها  تم تسليمهم إلى
العمل
رقم أربعة ، وضعوا لافتة عندما
يمشون هناك وفجأة رأوا
لافتة تقول ابتسامة على الكاميرا حتى لو
لم يكن لديك كاميرا ، فما زالوا
يتوقفون
مؤقتًا وربما يسيرون في الاتجاه الآخر
وأخيرًا تتبع الحزمة الخاصة بك وتشغيل
إشعارات التسليم
لساعة المستهلك اليوم أنا جين سوليفان